they refuse to follow the law while you
do that's why more kids are being shot
in schools completely defenseless than
an Army Ranger out in the battlefield
it's always hard when you deal with a
topic like this where there's a shooting
but it's the news and unfortunately
issues are politicized before the bodies
are even cold so my question of the day
this is for everybody out there if
you're in youtube comment or a DES crowd
or at NACA dude am I just looking for a
silver lining or does everyone else also
feel in the air the gun control movement
is largely dying kind of like the [ __ ]
hats in the hands up don't shoot I think
at the age of information online it just
can't hold up and I'm saying that with
the recent Santa Fe shooting for fusion
so they're our top 5 reasons or signs I
think that the gun control movement
today is dying so let's let's move on
here because it's been a very different
very different narrative right after
yeah Santa Fe then say parkland number
one the number one reason here is
because revolver and a shotgun were used
right in the latest innovation not only
not an assault weapon not only not a 9
millimeter carbine with a high-capacity
magazine not only not a semi-automatic
handgun but a revolver and a shotgun no
law would have stopped this aside for a
complete gun ban period there's nothing
I mean this is one of those issues that
from there going we're not coming after
your revolvers and shotguns they almost
advocated shotguns you don't need an
ar-15 it's harder to aim it's harder to
use
and in fact no need 30 rounds to protect
yourself by shot he's paid by big
Mossberg the number 2 reason is the term
assault weapons he sees with Santa Fe is
now being swapped for other terminology
pisses me off
combat weapon I saw from Charles blow at
the New York Times you see we took
combat based weapons I've heard so now
they moved from assault weapons because
we're so far removed pragmatically from
a soul weapons but the only common-sense
gun control legislation they wanted to
push right there's a common sense gun
control legislation we don't need
assault weapons out there but that's not
what it's about if you go read this this
column that was trending which was very
bizarre by the way enough is enough from
Charles blow it to it the New York Times
only had like dozens of retweets an
interaction
this has made me a single-issue voter
okay well this is my question to you
you're a single-issue voter Santa Fe
revolver and shotgun what common sense
gun reform are you pushing for it unless
it's an all-out ban we did this by the
way yeah we have b-roll of this video
that we did a long time ago where we
asked people to pick out what an assault
weapon was yeah and no one was able to
successfully take it out so and that
brings us to number three a reason that
I think you feel it I don't know if you
feel again do you feel it in the air
that it's very different now right after
Parkland you had David hog and as
breakfast club pose no more of that the
number three is a liberal overreach the
far left overreach they've tipped their
hand by praising far far left policies
that go far beyond any kind of eight in
assault weapons but here you go hear
from them we know that other countries
in response to one mass shooting have
been able to craft laws that almost
eliminate mass shootings written almost
Australia this is why the NRA puts up
videos that try to scare Americans they
go to emotions they go to fear you know
people want to take away your guns
nobody wants to take away people's guns
we just don't want to be any different
than Canada or Australia or Great
Britain okay in case you're confused in
Australia they literally did away
literally people are afraid that we want
to do exactly what Australia did but we
should just do exactly what Australia
did shotgun no go away Joe gun
statistics is number four yeah just
simple gun statistics by themselves are
a reason and the fact that people can
google them and find them so readily
available everyone they said that the
NRA wanted to block the CDC research
they said was a gun right the gun
lobbyists they want to block research no
no no actually we went out there as much
as possible so this is up there in
Washington Post and Charles blow was
linking to it in his article where they
tout a 12 percent rise in gun deaths and
we've talked about this is important gun
deaths were deaths being key not gun
murders gun deaths but then they go and
tip their hand with a negative slant and
this is where we're just reading the
same stat and just saying in a different
way where they say well there's also
been a 30% increase in defensive use of
firearms this means people are more able
and opt
to defend themselves and are preventing
crimes from being done to them than ever
before if you just contrasted the totals
right and don't take into account that a
significant portion of those twelve
percent increase in gun deaths include
criminals getting iced through defensive
use of firearms if you see a 30%
increase in self-defense right how many
rapes we're stopped hashtag me to how
many muggings were stopped when we talk
about a victim culture how many black
lives matter they were able to protect
himself here's a good example of a clip
that was making the rounds of a woman
protecting herself in a mugging let's
let's roll this and here you go guy
comes up woman with her kid she pulls
out a gun boom gone gone so we're
watching the same footage this is a
great example work that you're not gonna
find common gun if you watch that and
you go oh the horror
now we're watching the same foot that is
female empowerment yeah the statistical
alternative to that is being raped and
left for dead in an alley not in this
case because it's broad daylight here's
a stat that that are a brilliant
researcher reg found every now and then
I see a new statistic that gives me
chills yeah
send shivers down my spine and I don't
mean that in the Chris Matthews tingle
down my leg when Barack Obama became
president I mean actually I just it
becomes chilling unarmed women have
rapes against them completed so I mean
successfully completed in 48% of the
cases of an attack okay for women who
use guns against the attacker that
percentage drops to 0.09 percent
Wow go check that out at research gates
so think of this if there were any other
tool what people said we need to stop
the little sizing it and stop just
trying to play the blame game okay if
there were any other tool policy a
proposal on the table that could make it
543 plus times more likely that a woman
could make it out of a conflict without
being raped over 500 times of a higher
likelihood that you will not get raped
if you have a firearm in that conflict
wouldn't everyone support it and the
left and the right by shotgun no damn it
and put it in your purse yes exactly
because things women are came around
clown car pistol realities are so
undeniable that we get into the realm of
conjecture before we actually just
discuss the statistics and that's why I
think this is dying right now because
obviously people have anecdotal
experiences as you see now they're gonna
have more of those at a 30 percent
increase and defensive use of the
firearms to reflect what we have known
statistically to be true
this entire time speaking of which this
is number five and I think a big reason
the biggest of all that's glaring you
might say why didn't you get to this
sooner because it's this is the grand
finale an undeniable constant that's the
number five for when you look at all
these mass shootings 97% of mass
shootings occurred in gun-free zones
right why why can somebody just as
easily killed 10 people with a revolver
and a shotgun if someone can kill with
an ar-15 and just to give you another
example this Whoopi Goldberg again
saying the same thing that differently
not realizing how fundamentally
unintelligent it sounds here's for today
I guess I should let this sink in for a
second after Friday's high school
shooting in Texas more American students
have died from gun violence in 2018 than
US soldiers in combat why what's the
fundamental difference what is the
difference between all right line up the
students in a classroom close the door
it doesn't matter if I have an ar-15 a
shotgun revolver or African throwing
knives I can do what I want with you
versus I don't know a Marine a ranger
why is it that much more likely that
someone in a school could be like shot
shot like ducks in a row the soldiers
can shoot back Whoopie it sounds like
one of the earlier you think there's a
lot of gun control going on in the
battlefield Mary Mary an assault rifle
to be found I think that we have reached
a tipping point here where people now
with this this is why they have to
handle this very differently it still is
amongst the most deadly school shootings
that we've seen right same reason I
didn't cover that Sutherland Springs
which was far more deadly than parkland
because what did we have bad guy shoot
he was killed by a good guy with an
ar-15 and in this case we have a bad guy
who do not use an assault weapon we have
a bad guy who reflects the statistical
likelihood that it doesn't matter what
he uses or what kind of gun laws you
enact 97% of shootings are still going
to occur in gun-free zones and then that
lends itself to the new statistic that
there is a 30% increase in defensive
uses of firearms which of course
decreases your chances of being raped
and of course increases your overall
chances of living in a polite and
streamlined and overall society that is
quote unquote desirable that's a quote
unquote from myself
the tables on Al Gore and use the
internet to our advantage if you liked
this video subscribe by hitting the
subscribe button or the notification
bell next to it because subscribing
isn't enough watch one of these other
videos and you know listen you can you
can stick around you don't have to but
here's the thing the fact that you're
still listening to me saying stick
around as I say stick around and you're
sticking around bye we just added
another ad you just made me for more
sense